Texas Paul how are you this morning
I'm pissed off as a raccoon with a
jalapeno shoved up his butt I'm telling
you what he saw here I saw your video
yesterday you were in the cussing Pond
it sounds like he might still be there
I'm telling you this is this is this
ain't right this ain't right so you know
somebody asked you well let me ask you
real quick because I know you're a labor
guy I know you're you're a union gay and
yesterday was Labor Day and Joe Biden
gave a speech so I and I know you've got
a lot of stuff you want to talk about
with these Christian nationalists but I
really want to get your take
um because we watched part of the speech
live yesterday but I've been excited to
talk to you today about this and I don't
mean to step on your Christian
nationalism thing but I really I really
want to ask you
um what did you make of the speech
yesterday but more when Jill Biden
really set the trap for
um the manga Republicans the fascists in
this country this morning when he
basically said Wall Street is not what
built this country it's the working
people he's sending a trap here with his
speech yesterday and then this tweet
today but but Labor Day is an important
day in this country oh I lost him I lost
Texas Paul he'll be back don't worry
we'll get it back so what I was what I
was going to ask Texas Paul and I'll ask
him again when we get on here is that I
really want to know
um because labor is an important part of
this country it's the backbone of this
country and really unions are the
backbone of labor now the the right to
organize your labor and the right to
negotiate your labor has brought us
things like the five day week the
40-hour week
it's it's brought us a lot of things
something's good something's bad I think
one thing it did to us that I think had
unintended consequences was workplace
insurance I really think that that is an
unintended consequence that they could
not foresee when health care and the
expense of insurance was less back then
I think we got Texas Paul back now Texas
Paul are you there yeah sorry about that
I don't know what the heck happened wow
it happens it happens but I wanted to
ask you a question about Labor in
general and unions as well like I was
saying when you were getting back on
here unions are really the labor is the
backbone of our country and unions are
the backbone of Labor and the reason why
is because the unions are the reason why
we have the 40-hour week we have the
five-day week a work week and the other
things some things about unions had
unintended consequences that we're still
living with like workplace Insurance
um you know that that weren't
necessarily designed to hurt us overall
but have have over the years because of
the expense of Health Care and insurance
companies and where it's lettuce so it's
not all good but labor has had labor but
unions have had a positive impact on the
American workplace and the most
important thing that I think Joe Biden
is projecting here is that the American
working family is the thing that keeps
this country going and and I think
Americans gave that proof to themselves
again during the pandemic when the
essential worker quote unquote that's
what they called them the essential
worker
um and really honestly when they called
them essential workers my feeling was at
the time every single one of those
people that were deemed essential
workers should have been able to
unionize it doesn't matter what state
they were in because they were essential
right
um but give us your take on his speech
yesterday but also the Trap that he's
setting the political trap here because
remember we politicize everything here
and I think Joe Biden is setting a very
very very crucial political trap right
before this midterm when he says this
morning Maga Republicans don't
understand and that Wall Street didn't
build this country the American Working
Families have what's your take
absolutely fact 100 percent you know
Elon Musk is [ __ ] without everybody in
this Factory pumping out Teslas uh you
just it's a it's a forgotten
just a basic
basic fact of reality that nothing gets
done no one makes a dime unless
somebody's out there working and Labor
Day is a celebration of the worker and
Joe Joe Biden did an amazing job with
that speech he really did and you know
the whole greed is good generation that
came along from Reagan in the 80s it
totally screwed up the mindset in this
country for the last 40 years you know
everybody thinks that they're going to
be wealthy one day everybody wants to
think that you know everybody wants to
think and it's not until you get old and
wise that you realize that no the mass
vast majority of us are just going to
work a job we're going to take care of
our families and do the best we can for
each other and yeah we need to have
upward Mobility as a possibility
but that doesn't mean ignore the workers
that doesn't mean ignore the people that
are getting it done on a day-to-day
basis you know I mean they
everywhere you look
every billionaire out there
they didn't get rich off themselves you
know they all had an army of people even
Mark Zuckerberg and and all of these.com
billionaires that we like to think did
it all by themselves didn't Facebook
doesn't exist if Mark Zuckerberg didn't
put a team together to get it out to the
people he didn't do it alone he may have
come up with a concept and written the
original code and God bless them I'm
glad he's Rich you know I'm glad this is
a country where you can get rich
but damn it man everybody makes it on
the back of a worker
it's a worker that does it and the fact
that we've gotten away from Union so
much is why we're in so much trouble
today because when I lost
well and I was gonna say I I think I
think there's no uh other president in
history and you can tell me what your
view is Republican Democrat there's no
president that has been pro-union than
Jill Biden more pro-union than Joe Biden
and I think it's the reason why unions
are getting more and more popular is
because he's willing to lean into this
idea that the American worker is the
backbone
well and you know it's it's exactly yeah
I I yeah I think it was a great speech
but but that's not the magic of Joe
Biden Joe Biden comes from the Senate
he's quiet
he is behind the scenes he he's got Pete
bootage out there busting his ass you
know and and the rest of his
administration busting their ass on a
daily basis very quietly working for the
American people working for workers
that's what makes Joe Biden the freaking
magic man right now why his agenda is so
amazing is because it is because it's
he's not a Donald freaking Trump who
needs validation daily he's a grown-ass
man that knows it's a job and he's doing
the job and Republicans just don't know
what to do with it because they're out
there screaming looking for that guy to
fight against and Joe Biden's like you
know hey
I got work to do go go go be stupid it's
like like like he told the guy everybody
has the right to be an idiot so you go
be your idiot I'm gonna go ahead and get
this passed right right we're we're
gonna work hard if you want to be an
idiot be an idiot but if you want to
work hard speaking of idiots you got
some information here and I'm gonna
bring in Gabe Sanchez hey Gabe I thought
that I I honestly thought it was gonna
be speaking of idiots here's my code no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no well I mean hey if that's the
way you feel I don't know what you're
projecting no here's what I'm here's
what I'm gonna say you guys I have done
some research here in Texas Paul you're
on to a story here about these Christian
nationalists and that that's what I
wanted those are the idiots I wanted to
get to not speaking of a idiot idiots
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay okay so Texas Paul you have this
story that is that is ongoing and it
seems like they're using a crazy
strategy here
um to really push this Christian
nationalism
crazy like a fox crazy like a fox and
you have to let's start out with the
differentiation right there's a
Christian
and then there's a Christian nationalist
a Christian
is you know a real Christian that
follows the teachings of Jesus Christ is
by definition a wonderful person that's
not who we're talking about here we are
talking about the manipulators the
people in the Christian fascist
Christian nationalist movement these are
politicians these are lawyers you know
the old saying that Satan's gonna come
wrapped in a flag and and uh holding a
Bible
these are it I swear I promise you these
are what I'm talking about is Operation
Blitz it used to be called operation
Blitz up until 2019 where they got
caught
and then they rebranded for the free to
the freedom for all movement then they
rebranded again and rebranded again and
and what it is it's the uh Congressional
uh prayer conference Foundation
now everybody started the Congressional
prayer found uh conference or caucus
pardon me you know it's just a bunch of
senators to get together and pray right
well when they started a foundation [ __ ]
went downhill fast
what they've done is they've they've
and and Blitz is the is the key word
here is they cope they've come up with a
political strategy to come up with a
three-tier system of legislation that
they want to push and Blitz is the key
word here because they've pushed out
almost a thousand pieces of legislation
now and what they did is they created a
network where these politicians network
with State politicians and created this
group to push laws into place like here
in Texas this is what ties Texas to all
this because we've got and then God We
Trust law here there now what do you
mean in God we trust law
um because I think we've got some
graphics too but tell us about the in
God redress law because you were texting
me some stuff last night about this and
I I found it interesting because it
sounded like in God we trust as they
were trying to pass a law
um to well you really usurp the the
Constitution if they want Christianity
their Christian got in schools so tell
us what the uh In God We Trust law is
tell us what they did in Texas with this
thing
what the in God we trust laws are is
it's a law that says if someone presents
a school district with a poster that
says in God we trust on it which after
1954-56 is our is our national motto
right it's not original it's not
original they replaced e pluribus unum
one for many the the whole United part
of the United States with In God We
Trust
so what they had passed was a law that
says that if somebody prevents a school
a school district presents a school
district with a poster that says in God
we trust and has the national flag on it
and the state flag on it these school
districts have to frame it and then
place it prominently within a school so
that people can see it
so you're saying anyone anyone out there
can go to a school district they can
present a poster essentially that has
the words in God we trust on it the
American flag and the Texas flag and now
that school has to spend money and time
to to now present that in their
buildings is that what you're saying it
and hang it okay so so why is this so
important to this prayer caucus then and
why is this their strategy because it
sounds like to me that just just as more
Christian crying but you're saying it's
not just Christian crying that there's a
strategy here well it's not crime it's
not Christian crime see that's the thing
no crying crying whining
you know see here's the thing this is
the goal of these this that's that's a
what they call a tier one law okay that
is a law that's low hanging fruit easy
it's the national motto so they pass
these laws and by the way they modified
it now to where it can only be one per
school because somebody printed one in
Arabic and presented it and that wasn't
gonna fly oh yeah no they modified the
law they weren't talking about that God
oh no
oh my God Only God right yeah and what
you're saying is what you're saying is
if they get just one as long as the
Christians are first that's it
yeah and and like I said they presented
one with a rainbow flag but that's not
important what's important is they they
changed a lot where it's you've only got
a one per school okay so but the the
point of this is
to get somebody to object to it
see they don't consider this a win
because nobody's fighting it really you
got this one guy in Florida printing out
these weird ones but no nobody else
cares it's it's the national motto but
if they can get somebody to object to it
they've established an entire network
to put a microphone in in somebody's
face and get somebody objecting to this
they've got an entire network to push
this out to churches
and tell Christians see they don't
believe in God they're they're not you
they're not like you they don't they
they hate Christianity they it's the
opposition to these bills that they're
looking for right and this tier one bill
is designed to be a uh wet the whistle
okay it is to get the the legislation
moving little success get this done then
they move to a tier two bill which is a
little bit more offensive it's a doctor
doesn't have to do anything that offends
them
you know a Hobby Lobby doesn't have to
do anything that offends their religious
beliefs that's a tier two bill which is
a little bit riskier it's not again you
know it it pushing up against the law
now then come the tier three bills which
they've passed here in Texas which is
you've heard about the crisis we've had
with fost our foster care system
children dying children being pushed
into prostitution all kinds of horrific
things happening in our foster care
system well our foster care system also
has a law that says anybody that works
in the foster care system can apply
their religious beliefs as a litmus test
to anybody that takes in
a child
so if you're a nice atheist couple
and you're capable of caring for a child
and the person that gets your case
happens to be some radical
they can say oh no no no no no no better
better that this child stay in foster
care than get subjected to your atheism
wait wait so what you're saying is is is
is that in Texas right now that if if a
if a foster child is going to be paired
with with a parent with a family that
they can be raised and have stability in
community you're saying what you're
saying here is that that the the actual
representative of the state can say no
because you're not you're not the proper
religion that I want you to be as as
this as the state represented is that
what you're saying
yeah and that's horrific right right the
goal of that law
is to make you Tony me and anybody else
push against that law to say it's not
right to speak out against it to have a
to have a wokism or whatever they call
it right because there's an old like if
you you ask James Carville you ask any
political strategist why do people vote
right they don't vote to say thank you
they vote to say [ __ ] you right against
you and if they can take this back to
the churches which there's Gabe and I
were talking about this there's an
entire network every time one of these
laws somebody pushes back against it
they run it back to these churches and
blow it out to their to to to
all of their
members
we're attacking Christianity yeah is
that the map there yeah here's the map
this is the America prayer caucus
Network so this is this is their this is
the thing you're talking about Paul
where they have a network of of folks
that are that are actually instituting
uh these policies but not only that
they're they're using the strategy that
they're you're talking about here where
they're you know they're basically using
it as a trap you know I was talking
earlier that that Joe Biden's set in a
trap here and I think that's what this
is because you got another slide here
does this show how many members this is
yeah this is one one of the the few
within the network it's pray USA and
then this one if you take the uh the
scroll Banner off
yeah yeah let me take the scroll off
here
so this is so this is actually something
that Texas Paul was was chatting with me
this morning about but this actually
tells you you know how many government
leaders are part of this and then how
many of this you know American citizens
are also part of this so it's like you
know keeping a tally of people so these
are people that are members of this
prayer yes they are just people who who
have who have signed the oath of to this
to this ID this idea that they're gonna
push this stuff is it no it's it's worse
than that Tony they have weekly phone
calls where they update people like our
show like we're talking about it right
now they're going to cut excerpts out of
this show
and then they're going to take that
audio and they're going to play it over
a phone call to parishioners
all across the country
Michaels is a demon
you're attacking you hate Christians
Tony yeah oh well you hate Christians I
I don't like Christian nationalists
that's for sure I mean I think I think
you said it earlier that that there is a
difference between uh Christian
nationalism and actual like Christianity
people who you know I don't know that
will not be the message and this
Wednesday's phone call right right so so
you're saying so you're saying we're
going to be the subject on Christians
Minds this week is that what you're
saying
um you know I'll I'll tell you that um
um you know setting the [ __ ] here with
legislation but you know voting against
something is something I preacher right
I say it all the time I believe that is
true I really do believe that the
electorate votes no or votes against
something are votes based on their fear
and that's what you're saying they're
doing here is they're they're setting up
a a way to stoke fear and it's the same
it's the same kind of thing they do when
they when they break something you know
they intentionally break a system or
they potentially break something and
then they they're like oh well we fixed
it you know like you know they they do
this all the time so this is their MO
um what's this blitz thing what's this
blitz graphic that you have here what is
this here
the that is the key word is to come from
so many directions that and and they
were actually publishing
that the Playbook so that they could
pass it out to pastors and each of their
state legislators and and members of
Congress they could pass out so that you
notice that Republicans are always on
one talking point
this was that this was that this is this
where the Marjorie Taylor dream talk is
coming from
exactly the Watchman on the wall the
Watchman on the wall That's from this
yeah and what
it's just really just the sad and I want
to reach out to Christians when I say
this if you're a Christian and you hear
this
the Democratic party is that am I My
Brother's Keeper party right
we push legislation for health care to
fund school lunches and that's what I
want to get into for just I won't take
but a second
this is the kind of manipulation you're
up against they want you angry but they
don't want to do [ __ ] about what you
believe
school lunches are Republicans Tony let
me ask you a question just a generic
question real quick are Republicans for
or against school lunches funding school
lunches against it
[ __ ] and I can prove it okay I can
prove it they give lip service to being
anti-entitlement right right but they
quietly passed a law through this
network
to give religious schools Title IX
exemption oh so you're saying they're
very strategic about their social their
socialism they get USDA funding at
Christian Schools if a church has a
school it gets funding from the USDA
like a public school to to fund their
school lunch programs hmm you and if you
notice when they oppose that school
lunch program they can filibuster
anything in the world I mean they can
get the votes to anything but that one
they just can't seem to find the votes
to filibuster why it's a revenue stream
from the government and we Democrats
being our you know am I on My Brother's
Keeper party we're like hell yeah feed
kids it doesn't matter if they're in
public schools or private schools let's
do this so it was a bipartisan Bill to
get to create this Title IX exemption
well yeah because there's no there's no
way that the Democrats in this country
are gonna are gonna appear to not be for
children eating I mean here
well because honestly I think one of the
best things that came out of the
coronavirus package is that children
didn't have to worry about paying for
lunch and neither did parents um when it
came to schools we just did the the
thing that we should do with education
and feed children like that's part of
education and I know it sounds weird and
some people are like oh that's just not
how it happened when I was a kid yeah
that's because we had our head up our
ass and we didn't realize that that
feeding children fuel food is good for
their education and Democrats are for
that so what you're saying is so what
you're saying is Democrats across the
border for the school lunch Republicans
are very selective about it it seems I
mean that seems to be their nature the
other thing too though is like I don't
know how much accounting or oversight uh
goes into this but the fact that they're
willing to take money right the big
question in my mind is how much money is
actually being used right because we
know Republicans love to cut Corners
love to cut costs so they can increase
profits on their margins so the next
thing that I wonder and I don't have the
answer for it but the next thing I
wonder is
how much of that funding for school
lunches is actually being used for
nutritious meals and lunches and not
just saying okay here's something that
is like bare minimum of what a human can
can like ingest and the rest of the
money goes toward our program to either
combat the food program or use it for
other
anti-democratic uh yeah yeah right let
me scare the [ __ ] out of you Gabe and
answer that question
there's I last Sunday I did a show where
I talked about the televsky case that is
coming to the Supreme Court it is a
million ton freight train heading right
at us and we're tied to the tracks and
it's going to happen
where's this case this is the one from
South Carolina Indiana
okay because I know there's another one
in South Carolina that's coming up to
you I wasn't sure what's what's this
title 42 USC code U.S code 1983 is the
statute used if say what Gabe is talking
about this school didn't use the funding
that they received from the USDA to to
pay for lunches say they built a big ass
gold cross out front instead
a family member that attends that school
could say hey you're violating my rights
you you took money to feed my kid and
you didn't feed my kid right and they
could sue and that was the oversight
when they the telesky case came forward
the judge in that case the federal judge
said you don't have standing to Sue this
is a this is a government matter you
have no standing
they appealed it and the appeals court
remanded it back
and said hold the trial the judge said
no I'm not going to hold the trial he
appealed the appeal and the Supreme
Court quietly stuck it on their Shadow
docket
they took the case a case that has never
been tried they took the case so so what
what is this what is that what is the
sides of the case here and what is the
pending or the pending result that
they're looking for because someone's
looking for a result here
right that means that if the federal
government gives the state money for a
road or for in this case it was to
through Medicaid uh to to care for an
elderly person the the state-owned uh
facility
did you know they the wife sued that
they didn't do a good job that they they
they
kept him medicated constantly and in
other words in other words the
government gave the facility money and
they didn't do with that money what they
were supposed to because they didn't
give her spouse care is that what is
that the corrects of it okay that's the
gist of the case okay but when they say
you don't have standing
there goes the oversight because this
statute is something that goes all the
way back to Scalia I hated that son of a
[ __ ] but it goes all the way back to
Scalia and and and all of the
conservative Justice on the on the
Supreme Court have wanted to gut
1983.
title 42 USC 1983 because it is
oversight for what states have to do
with money given to them by the federal
government so it is that essentially
no sorry continue no go ahead I was just
gonna ask you so does that now create
precedent for any state entity that
takes get Federal funding to say you
gave us the money and we did what we
wanted with it and you can't say
anything about it
it's a free-for-all what it means is
what it means is the federal government
will have to a stop giving States money
which is what they really want because
the billionaires don't want to pay taxes
right or or create a massive massive
infrastructure larger than the IRS and
the justice department combined to chase
every dollar down to every school every
project every you know Medicaid Program
every everything to oversee it this
sounds like a trip
because they're going to say oh big
government I mean Jesus Christ they they
announced that over the next five years
they're going to hire IRS agents because
20 000 of the retiring we have 30 000
less than we need and we really need
more to to do the work that the agency
is doing that well the work that they're
not doing like you said earlier when we
were talking about Labor like the only
way that [ __ ] actually gets done is
humans and Americans citizens workers
actually do the [ __ ] work like big
government isn't just this big building
that we keep adding on to the problem is
is when you have regulation like this
and they set this up this way you have
to have bureaucracy to make sure the
taxpayers money is going where they want
right and Republicans don't get it
twisted they love big government they
love the bigger the government gets the
more they can demonize it the more they
can get people scared of it the more
they can actually make sure make sure
that their constituents vote in that
fear so tell me what does this Supreme
Court case have to do with this prayer
caucus what do you see that these these
two things are connected see let's let's
tie it together so everybody can
understand it okay you have this caucus
this this organization isn't it of of
politicians and lawyers the as tied in
churches
to feed specific information they pass
these laws anytime a real win for them
is to when a law doesn't pass they've
proposed almost a thousand they've
passed somewhere around 30. of these
laws every loss they take back to the
churches to enrage their parishioners
and say we on the left are anti-god then
quietly what they do is work with us to
do God's work am I my brothers it's the
entitlement right get the entitlement
and it feels like I'm throwing a plate
of spaghetti at you right
that was the point that's why they
called it project Blitz it was to come
at so many angles
so many different directions that it was
difficult to fight against
it was difficult to coalesce anybody to
resist any of it and what it boils down
to is after the televsky case
not only are they going to have Revenue
coming out of the government because
they've quietly been working you know on
programs like we just mentioned but
they're also going to have an enraged
voter base who who you know Tony as you
mentioned in our conversation after Roe
a lot of church people said whoa
wait a minute you're going way too far
right well they're using this program to
re-enrage them so that they show up at
the polls because what because what
you're saying there is that they may not
they may not show up to vote for Maga
Republicans because of Roe they may
abstain but the churches may be able to
get them engaged on a different issue
other than abortion right because that's
their aim here this really smells and I
um and I know I know it stinks to high
heaven this really smells like Steve
Bannon and that stinks like [ __ ] to be
quite honest does this does this I mean
where where does Peter Thiel and Steve
Bannon and some of these other [ __ ]
fall in on this because it really smells
like it just doesn't have to do with
churches and Christianity that they're
using that infrastructure to really push
this well they're just I mean they're
just using it to keep people you know
like Texas Paul said they're just using
it to keep people in the rage but the
other thing too is that you what you
mentioned I thought was interesting
they've introduced or proposed a
thousand and they've only passed 30 but
I would you know if I was a wait a
thousand bills
that's what he said he's right at a
thousand though and right in a thousand
but they've only passed 30. so if I had
to [ __ ] if I had two uh imagine right if
I had to put a bet down on this
I would say that they intentionally put
out bills that are just random gibberish
not anything of value but they go to
their Parish they go to their caucus
their their foundation and they say look
we went forward and we tried to pass
this bill now no one of course in that
in that Parish or their congregation or
what have you was ever going to read
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but they tell them
look we proposed this bill about XYZ
about how the Democrats and the left are
trying to take this away from us and we
as as you know God-fearing Christians
want to estab establish this right for
us
I guarantee there's probably 500 of
those thousand bills that are complete
[ __ ] but are just used as a talking
point is yeah we submitted it like it's
on the docket or whatever and of course
when the judge gets it like this makes
no sense it's not there and then they
say okay cool yeah we'll just leave
right but they're able to use that as
fodder and fuel to say look we're
fighting for you but they just won't let
us do it it's this we need to make sure
that we have the elected officials in
the state district level to make sure
that we actually are able to pass these
you know tier two tier three whatever it
might be type of loss so anyway that's
what I that's what I think and I have no
idea if that's true but I would imagine
they're you know intentionally
just like they're doing with the school
lunches they're intentionally injecting
you know frivolous cases or frivolous
things to propose to the court and then
taking that as a win because they know
they'll lose
you know actually you're absolutely
right on and it's not speculation you
had Lee Caron is her name if you want a
googler you can actually pull her
picture up she's a VP now she used to be
the director she's a VP of uh the cpcf
or the you know the Congressional uh
prayer caucus Foundation
um
they rebranded project Blitz to freedom
for all she got caught in a phone call
saying okay they're on to us so what we
did is we're a step ahead of them we
eliminated project blitz so if you
Google project Blitz right now or if you
go to projectblitz.com which used to be
a website that they ran to pass
information on it's under construction
there's nothing there but but how
convenient yeah yeah right they better
put your [ __ ] hard hats on because
democracy is coming for them that's all
I gotta say
but what you were talking about with
with with Bannon I'll do you one better
Milo yiannopoulos okay he's also
I'm not kiddies wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
for anyone who doesn't know who my
little Annapolis is of course he was a
predominant
um talking head with Breitbart yeah and
it's pretty big in 2016. yeah well and
and you know um to be quite honest Bill
Maher is the one who destroyed him right
and and what happened was
um he was going to get a book deal he
was really a rising star and the reason
why is because he was one of these and I
don't know if I'm saying it correctly
but he's a femboy was he claimed to be
gay now he's converted back I mean he
had a husband at the time
um he was just a really a right-wing
fascist
um which he didn't he didn't portray or
he didn't fit the model but that's what
they liked about him and then uh Bill
Maher had him on
and people were really upset that Bill
Maher had him on at the time but Bill
Maher said you know sunlight is the best
disinfectant and it absolutely
disinfected him
um and he had to totally Rebrand and
turn around so is this part of that
rebranding is is this uh
yeah he's gone from being the Milo
yiannopoulos with the painted
fingernails and the jewelry and the I'm
gay well and he has died here and I'll
get married
I mean really honestly they should do
that
he's now if you didn't know it I mean he
is he's a he has found God
he is a straight Christian man now he
found Jesus he's re-banding her both
right well he's working with Michael
Taylor green right
huh isn't he working with Margarita
green now he he's been working with
anybody who will stand on the stage next
to him he is desperate to get his face
out there yeah Marjorie said anybody
anybody and you know you were talking
about Bannon he and Bannon tied up
together and they are working within
this whole project Blitz freedom for all
framework pushing this [ __ ] out is this
the same kind of thing that they did in
in 2020 and really 2021 with the CRT
[ __ ] I mean is it the same kind of
nonsense where they're going to school
boards and they're yelling and screaming
just queuing on [ __ ] into a microphone
and the school board members are like
look this is a [ __ ] public meeting
this is not a place for your [ __ ]
Facebook feed to show up and and a lot
of them were shutting down meetings they
were saying oh they're silencing us and
they were claiming they're making
Sciences they weren't being silenced you
just don't have the right to go in an
official proceeding and just say a bunch
of garbage it's not a thing that that's
it's not that's not part of freedom of
speech your freedom of speech is outside
the public proceeding not inside of it
it just and toning think about this man
these dumb idiots chewing on cannot put
a sentence together [ __ ]
that are just stupid as you can [ __ ]
be if you listen to them speak we're
walking into school board meetings and
all I mean it didn't matter what state
what you know all said the exact same
thing yep well yeah because it was this
well some of them it felt like this is
where it originated it felt like to me
like some of them were reading a script
that was given to him through some sort
of thing now a lot of it like they were
just reading their Facebook feed but it
really did seem like they were reading a
script right like here's the points
you're supposed to say here's the things
you're supposed to yell into a
microphone it reminds me a lot of of
Sinclair broadcasting and how they have
all of you know I'm sure you've seen
compilations where it's one new station
then a second then a third then a fourth
and they're all saying the exact same
thing and in that same way
they're doing this for you know they're
obviously going in locally and rising up
through the ranks but it's one of those
things where it's like yeah they're just
regurgitating the same thing because
they saw it on Facebook or if they saw
it here and they're just like I don't
know what I'm talking about
but this person sounds like they know
what they're talking about so I'm just
going to regurgitate it right and then
you hear all this like nonsense is that
why it seems like a grass you know they
call it Grassroots but is that why it
seems like that because there's
something more Sinister behind this I
mean obviously they have they have an
end agenda it's not like oh well we want
to empower these people that's not what
it's about it's about an end agenda
well that's where Steve Bannon comes in
you know he's got this the he's got a
podcast he's got a talk show they they
get these cue nuts you know that he
talks to those people he gets dirty he
keeps he is the buffer between the oh my
God I am a a you know super Christian I
just want room 219 in the capital to so
that we can get together and pray for
America you know I mean he's the buffer
between those he's even got a Jesus
Christ have you ever said he's got a
Jesus and a like up on his he's got a
Jesus and a cross that's kind of gross
but you know Woody why do you think he's
doing that right he is the what ties
these these beer guzzling farting freaks
viewing on free
farters here okay I don't wanna I don't
want to offend nobody yeah but Tony
you're not claiming to be a paragon of
the church my man no no I'm just raising
your family doing the best you certainly
not certainly not I mean maybe maybe the
Church of beer farts but other than that
I I don't I don't claim to be but no no
all joking aside what you're saying
saying is is that Steve Bannon is
getting these people together in a space
where you have these crazy conspiracy
theory nut bags who are not who are not
Christians and really aren't really
claim their entire lives they haven't
been Christians it's kind of like Donald
Trump claiming now to be a Christian
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you know everything Christian your
entire life you never exposed any kind
of belief that would appear to be
Christian and and now he's a Christian
nationalist right all of a sudden which
it it seems like you're saying the Milo
yiannopoulos the Steve bannons here's a
picture of uh Milo here and I just wanna
I just wanna uh specify here he is an
intern for Marjorie Taylor okay so this
is his intern back he is he is working
his way back up and this is in turn as
the straight uh fixed
yeah yeah well well so maybe you can
find a before picture of what what he
what he did look like in the
transformation that he's made to get
into this Christian nationalist movement
um because what you're saying is is that
this Christian nationalism number one
it's not Christian it's actually
nationalism just like national socialism
in Germany was not socialism it was
nationalism they're they're disguising
it as something and the way that they're
disguising it is they're collecting an
army of of people who they're duping by
lying to them because you're saying they
may even use this video right here to
lie to these folks right right they may
use this video to say look at this Tony
Michaels Gabe Sanchez Dick's ball
they're crazy they're lefties they're
the lefties as Ted Cruz calls my
distance lefties well you got it you
gotta play the victim you gotta you
gotta say that they they are the bully
right there's the projection the
hypocrisy you need an enemy if you have
an enemy or a boogie man that says this
person's coming to take away whatever
that you hold you know dear to your
heart
then then you have yourself oh great we
have now a face on the wall and we have
a Target that we can go for it and as
long as we invoke that fear and that
outrage and we can keep them going which
is like what Texas Paul was talking
about earlier it's like you get those
easy tier one things those are wins
great right but you need something that
will be a forever
kind of problem right you'll never be
able to fix it but if we stay in Rage
and you give us money and we do this and
we do that then we can keep fighting
this fight against the left or the Deep
state or you know the the the Satan
worshiping uh Democrats or whatever it
might be well this is where it gets
dangerous I you know I hate to expose
myself here you know I'm I am an old
Hill Billy I am but I actually like to
educate myself a little bit there's a
quote from Voltaire if you can get a man
to believe absurdities you can get him
to perform atrocities
and if you can take a Christian in this
country and you can take him and tell
him that the Democrats who want to
provide health care that want to provide
these school lunches we're the ones that
provide the funding for it we're the
ones that want you in a union so that
you can get a good wage we're the ones
that want you to be able to work one job
and take care of your family we're the
ones that want a a minimum wage that
will allow you to afford an apartment in
Most states a minimum wage won't even
get you in an apartment
we we're the ones that want to take
anybody that has the education I mean I
mean the intelligence pardon me and can
make it into college and can and earn
the grades we want to benefit Society by
paying for their education these are all
Christian things these are all the
backbone the work that Jesus said to do
if you can convince Christians
that I
am the enemy
you can convince him to commit
atrocities you can convince him to to
raid the capital on January 6th you can
convince him that uh CRT which is of
course that's taught in just a handful
of law schools at at at you know you've
got to be pursuing a Juris doctorate to
even get into this course is somehow
being pushed all through your high
school and you can convince them to join
white supremacy groups you can convince
them people that would normally be
decent human beings going to church
you can fill their heads because you
know we all know what filling the space
is right I mean we all know there's only
so much time people have to take
information in and if you can fill that
space with this [ __ ]
and make me the enemy they will vote
they will give Republicans power so
Republicans will use that power
to create a fascist State and the way
they get to a fascist state is by
promising the Christians a Christian
nationalist state right well and because
they believe absurdities that brings up
a good point because
um convincing someone uh that that isn't
true and then when it comes to fruition
it seems to be true only only
perpetuates this idea that's why that's
why they're trying really hard like
Lauren bobert who is a Christian
nationalist Margaret Taylor Greenstein
they keep saying this is not a democracy
it's not a democracy it never is
democracy it's a republic it's a
constitutional republic we don't have a
democracy we don't live in a democracy
and the audience has probably seen this
out there in their comments section even
just trolls coming in and saying this
isn't a democracy this isn't a democracy
because what you're saying is is exactly
this if if the majority of people who
are in your army who are your supporters
don't believe you're a democracy when
they get get their democracy taking away
from them they don't realize it was
taken away because they didn't think
they had one in the first place there
wasn't one so if they don't believe
there was one then they don't have it
taken away from but I guess the the
audience probably wants to know is how
do what do we do Paul what do we do
Texas Paul what the hell do we do then
if we are the people out there we're the
party out there For the Working Man for
the American working family if we're the
ones that are going to put our necks on
the line for this legislation to make
sure all children not just children in
public schools but children in parochial
schools and children in general uh get
food get to be fed and we do the things
that we as in as a country see as quote
unquote Christian but more moral than
than Christian that we're helping our
fellow man
um you know
what do we do then to not only do the
things that we need to do to create
these policies for more equity and
equality
and Liberty in this country but to make
sure we're not feeding into this trap
what do we do is there messaging thing
that we can do or what do you think
you know it's really really difficult I
had a discussion along these lines with
Ben Marcellus
we were talking about Tendencies on the
left and some of the things that we've
really got to we've got to work on
ourselves cleaning up our own backyard
first and
it's in our nature when we see something
that's not right to speak out it's in
our nature to say hey cut that [ __ ] out
and we've got to learn to pick our
fights
if they want to put
you know our national motto even if you
don't agree with it being our national
motto in schools
ignore it
just ignore it
don't don't feed the trolls put it that
way don't give them opposition to you
know we have to pick our fights we do so
that we can get Christians in this
country to hear us I mean because right
now they can't hear us we're the enemy
we're the left we're the radical left
everything that they write we're the
radical left man the radical left here
comes crazy ass radical Paul with his
[ __ ] health care for everybody you
know that's Socialist Communist son of a
[ __ ]
goddamn you're going to ruin this
country by making sure that people don't
go broke because of a health care bill
because it's ridiculous I mean yeah I
mean it's so damn stupid if a guy that's
laying bricks breaks his arm you know
hey send them to the hospital get him a
cast so he can come back to work you
know I mean that's just stupid that's
just communism right there right sounds
sounds like it to me
it just I I think I think the messaging
is important and I think what you're
saying is is that uh and I I like that
you put it don't feed the trolls starve
the trolls because I've me and Gabe have
talked about trolls in our feeds before
and I I honestly don't give them any
fodder like like a lot of times I read
their [ __ ] I actually laugh because some
of some trolls are good but the ones I
really like to laugh at are the horrible
yeah like they don't even know how to
troll well they'll either starve
themselves or someone else you know
because this is this is typically how it
goes a troll will try to attack and then
you don't really acknowledge it uh and
then someone else chimes in to be like
well you're wrong this is [ __ ]
whatever and they go back and forth and
usually how it ends is that troll gets
just demolished by either one person or
many people to call them out for their
[ __ ] and then if then that troll
goes and they get really mad and then
they block that person that that
attacked them for calling them out and
that's how it normally goes so you
either starve them or they get so
embarrassed that they Retreat and then
they don't ever come back again which I
think is funny when you're looking at a
group that's so triggered by getting
called out for being a fascist right so
mean that was such such it was so mean
by President Biden went on the flip of
the coin they immediately call everyone
else you know I'm rubber you're glue you
know it's like you're a fascist I'm not
a fascist it's like I quit you didn't
fire me you know it's that type of that
but isn't that what this is Paul I mean
yes it's on a whole nother level it's on
a legislative level they're legislative
trolls not Twitter trolls or Facebook
trolls or or Tic Tac trolls right this
is a whole nother legislative uh troll
level where we have Steve Bannon and
here's here's the picture of Milo before
and then there's the after
um so these are these are exponentially
more dangerous trolls than the ones that
show up in your in your Twitter feed
these are people who are these trolls
are passing legislation but isn't that
what they're doing is is to to do this
I'm rubber your glue that's exactly what
you're saying when they pass this
legislation they we go wait a second you
can't hang up a sign that says In God We
Trust in this school you can't do that
and then like oh and then they yell and
scream and then all their Troll Army
comes and protects them and and and and
and pounces on it and they say oh I'm
rubber you're glue what bounces off me
sticks to you and then they pass more
legislation and more legislation because
they have this support behind them even
though it's delusional they still have
this support behind him is that is that
what you're saying is happening in a
and I'll do you one better than that
here in Texas instead of fixing the
power grid
instead of dealing with the tragedy that
we just had in Uvalde and doing
something about it instead of that
we're talking about In God We Trust
posters
if there isn't anything more [ __ ] sad
than that right and that's the point do
you that's why Beto's doing so well in
Texas though is that he's absolutely
letting these distractions he's going to
these communities he's not holding
rallies like Beto is not going to big
huge stadiums and having a hundred
thousand people listen to him do some
bit Beto is going and he's taught he
stands on an actual soapbox like I've
seen videos of him standing on a soapbox
in front of dozens of people who are
very interested into what he has to say
and not just sycophants I mean there are
there are better supporters there but
there are people in Trump hats and Trump
shirts and there there are some that are
yelling and screaming the Greg Abbott
supporters into borns but there are
those there are those Trump voters who
are sitting there going maybe this guy
isn't so bad maybe I should listen to
what he has to say because it seems like
he could be the next Governor I might
want to know what he has to say I might
want to know where he stands yeah and
there and some of them are listening
intently so much so that he's signing
their Maga hats I mean so are you saying
that we should take the better model and
and ignore the the noise and just talk
about our democracy what is important to
us you know get down back to Bare Bones
you don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill you want children to start
school at three instead of five and be
safe when they're in school you don't
want children to be hungry you don't
want people not to have Health Care
Mental Health Care specifically because
we have a huge problem with that right
now of access to mental health care I
mean all these simple things that
communities and community members want
it seems like Beto's it's laying the
groundwork for the perfect model to
really really make this this trolling
this legislative trolling really just
fall flat on its face if you're running
for office use the Beto model talk about
getting things done if you're on a show
and they ask you one of these [ __ ]
culture War questions
ignore it don't answer it talk about
what you're doing
if you're in office
follow the Biden example
just get [ __ ] done
and when they pull you up in front of a
camera and they want to talk about CRT
or they want to talk about in God we
trust or any of these other damn issues
talk about what you're doing
talk about what you're doing this is
what I'm doing for the American people
Maga
are an existential threat to our
democracy I'm the president and I will
defend our democracy that's it well and
I think that's what you do I think what
the people out there the audience can do
is perpetuate these messages and follow
these people that are following the
better model the the Biden model and
really play into it lean into your
democracy engage in the ballot engaging
about Texas Paul I know you stayed
longer than you usually do but what a
great conversation today my pleasure
it's been great tell us tell us where we
can find each other the audience where
you want them to go I know you're you're
doing some videos over on your YouTube
channel too but give us a give us a
Shameless plug here
hey you know every day I'm pumping stuff
out on with the Midas media Network
they are the Midas Network they are
doing God's work man they really are
when I say that we are the party of I Am
My Brother's Keeper we are the party of
I Am My Brother's Keeper I am here to
fight for what is right I am here to
fight for your family I'm here to fight
for Works what works for you
and that's exactly what Midas is doing
and yeah I'm I'm running a little show
every every Sunday to counter the Sunday
shows because the media's gotten so bad
um lately that I've just said screw it
I'll run my own Sunday show I'm doing it
on my own YouTube channel uh about a
half hour of comment commentary every
every Sunday at Paul TX 890 or just
search the road Texas Paul and and hit
my YouTube channel as well hit the
Subscribe button if you can
well we'll we'll put the uh we'll put
the link to your yeah to your YouTube
channel also down in the description so
after the show I'll put it in there that
way uh people can find it pretty easy
um so everyone can find your Channel
with just a click of the link so again
uh don't miss Texas Paul on the Midas
touch Network and also go follow him
over on his YouTube channel so you can
catch his Sunday his Sunday commentary
um and and and don't forget to subscribe
here because every Tuesday he comes and
joins us and Paul it's getting better
and better and better every Tuesday
um we're getting pretty damn good at
this uh Texas ball Tuesday stuff it
seems like can I say one last thing yeah
go ahead
Tony you and Gabe are running Bar None
one of the best podcasts that have ever
been produced ever you do it daily you
bust your asses to help people and man I
tell you what if people are not
subscribing and coming to watch this
they're out of their damn Minds if
you're sitting through [ __ ] on CNN
if you're sitting through [ __ ] on
Fox or you're sitting there watching
MSNBC try to be polite instead of coming
to Tony and getting the real deal where
he'll tell somebody [ __ ] you when
something's wrong
I don't know what you're doing with your
life I really don't I mean because you
are running one of the best podcasts
ever created and people need to know
that
well we got a damn good show here and we
like to bust down doors and kick ass and
take names and I I do not I do not take
prisoners here uh and I know I know with
the work the great work of Gabe Sanchez
the graphic art and the videos that he
produces and the show that we produce
um we are we are going to be the fastest
growing political commentary show and I
I know I know eventually because there's
more and more audience members that are
joining us every single day so at like
Texas fall do us a favor subscribe to
our our YouTube channel and also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google and your favorite
directories everywhere but but more than
that stay tuned stay tuned every day
come and get your news because we do the
[ __ ] list Roundup we bring on important
guests that are pro-democracy like Texas
Paul and others and we want to make sure
that we're leaning into democracy not
just for this election but for our
country's future and that is what we are
committed to here doing every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific and 2
Tuesday is always a special day for us
because we get the mightiest Mighty
favorite Texas ball Texas ball thanks
for joining us I can't wait to come back
next Tuesday to see what you got for us
hopefully we'll we'll round up some more
crazies and see if we can round about
you know I'll be watching too to see if
we show up on this um these Christians
oh yeah now I'm curious yeah I want to
see if we show up on this I want to see
where we fall so Texas ball thanks for
joining us
you won't see it it'll be on a private
conversation nobody gets to hear wow
it'll be on a just they'll just pump it
out to the pastors and the next thing
you know in church on Sunday you'll be
hearing about did you hear what that
some [ __ ] said about I
you know it actually you're you're
you're traveling after my heart here
when you say that a bunch of Christian
nationalists are going to call me a son
of a [ __ ] oh my God
nothing makes me smile more and more
happy on Tuesday than Texas ball
reassuring me that a bunch of Christian
nationalists are going to make sure that
they know that I'm a son of a [ __ ] and
I'm the son of a [ __ ] in their Grill
Texas ball thanks for joining us we'll
see you next Tuesday Tuesday my friend
everyone go follow Texas Paul on YouTube
we'll put it down in the description uh
after the show we'll put it down there
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this break